more detail should we with a business
secretary Grant chaps um quite useful
isn't it that he's here this morning for
us um it's part of your portfolio
devastating for those involved yeah I
look at we've been working on this for a
long long time I chair the UK National
Space Council and decade also work's
gone into this
um but uh actually your report just said
space is difficult
um everyone's used to seeing Rockets
which explode from the launch pad and
what have you the great thing about this
technology is that you know no one was
harmed the the the the pilots came back
in the in in the aircraft it didn't work
I've no doubt that they'll pick
themselves up dust themselves off and
they'll go again once they find out what
exactly went wrong with it and we've
seen this in space programs throughout
time what sort of time schedule do you
think I don't know and I haven't had the
chance this morning to catch up with the
folks involved in in the uh you know
detail of the program but there was
clearly a problem at that latter age
which prevented firing either for a
sufficient amount of time or it didn't
fire at all I don't know which it is to
reach space but this is actually
partially proven technology because
satellites have already been launched
from this system and I think actually
also for Cornwall and for new key to
have got this far it was a big moment
nonetheless yesterday and actually
there's another six locations in the UK
including a couple in Scotland in Wales
so you know there's a big chunk of money
uh and Export and jobs to be had from
International Space I was listening to
Lord mandelson on a podcast over the
weekend and he said that he come to you
to offer guidance on being business
secretary because he used to do it yeah
um was it useful meeting yes it was and
just so your viewers know I actually met
with all of my predecessors as far back
as Lord heseltine Michael heseltine
mandelson my immediate predecessors so
I've tried to meet with everybody who's
been in this role they're a one two that
I'm getting to because I think it's
really important to learn from the past
find out what has worked what hasn't
made my own judgments on it and I it's
for me it's a part of settling into the
job and doing my own research he did
also say as part of that podcast at the
minimal level of service during strikes
that plan legislation was unworkable I
don't agree because it works in places
like France and Italy and Spain Germany
other places have minimum service or in
some cases with the NHS safety type
levels which mean that if you call an
ambulance for example you know that it
will turn up if it's a heart attack or a
stroke I think it's really important we
already know that though don't we
because they are our workers have said
that they will turn up yeah so the
problem we had in the recent strikes was
that the Royal College of Nursing that's
the nurses did make that agreement to
the National level so there was some
guarantee unfortunately the ambulance
unions didn't do that last time round so
there was a sort of regional or postcode
Lottery that's the thing we want to
avoid and that's why today I'll
introduce a minimum safety levels and
service levels for key public services
to make sure that we don't end up in a
situation where people's lives are put
at risk while still respecting the right
to withdraw labor and strike do you
think that people who work in the NHS
work hard enough because uh apparently
it was suggested by the health secretary
to a member of the unite Union I believe
that they need to work harder if they
want to pay yeah I don't I don't think
that's actually a a correct reflection I
think what the health secretary was
saying was the same as the things I was
saying um perhaps with the rail strikes
which is through thankfully through
technology and modernization is now
perfectly possible often to do things
much more efficiently in the past and
this is a challenge for the whole of
um Society public sector and perhaps the
NHS in particular that we know there are
always more efficient ways of doing
things and if you look at how our own
you know lives have changed you were
just telling me you were reading a book
on your on your phone for example
something which 10 years ago you
probably wouldn't have done there are
many many new things which have come in
which could make a practice of of
healthcare practice of running Railways
and other things is much more efficient
and I think what the health secretary
was saying is let's try and take
advantage of those things and that's our
route to being able to pay people for
for greater productivity but one of the
allegations that's being leveled against
this government is you're intransigence
at dealing with unions and trying to get
to a deal so that this country is not
brought to its needs by strike so
actually it's that was leveled against
you I was going to say it's probably
worth
um because actually in some of the
coverage of these strikes what hasn't
come through is the fact the government
has entirely accepted entirely the
independent pay review bodies are
recommendations
no but the independent pay review bodies
who actually don't apply in every area
but they do in in the NHS and they they
took into account and they said look
we've used the projection of inflation
uh which was more or less correct in
order to to make this pay recommendation
now the government has accepted it it's
the unions have said we're not accepting
that independent pay review body now if
that's the case they need to present
evidences to why that's not correct and
they haven't accepted it and what we've
said as a government is look we're going
to publish all of our data we're going
to we're going to show why we've gone to
the independent pay review body with
these with our information please do the
same and that's part of of why getting
around the table has been helpful this
year but you didn't get around the table
did you with the rmt you didn't want to
have anything to do with them so so with
it it's slightly different in different
sectors of the economy but with a rail
the Secretary of State doesn't run rail
in the same way as in the NHS for
example there's a much closer
relationship in in some senses so for me
what I was saying is look at in the end
it's between the employers and the
employees which in the in the train
sector uh happens to be Network rail to
be the people um speaking I've noticed
the principal objection to it and
actually whatever it takes to get these
things settled interestingly of course
my two successors at transport have done
exactly what the unions were saying
which is to to speak to them and that
still hasn't settled the strikes at
which but they do feel that they've got
further as I said I had and ask the
union leaders segment on the show and
the rmt guys the deputy not um not Mick
Lynch and he was saying they're getting
further with Mark Harper do you think
he's a better transport secretary yeah
well maybe he is maybe that's maybe
that's the answer but but look frankly
getting these things settled is the most
important thing and in rail in
particular uh where particular it
depends on on the area but but train
drivers for example uh whose average
salaries are are really quite much
higher no they tend to mostly not that's
right they tend to be um the guards and
what have you yeah but actually for the
r d and for a lot of the people that
they represent there are a lot of very
good Common Sense things that they could
do to massively improve safety and
productivity on the radio on the railway
for example we still have usually blokes
walking down tracks knocking the track
rather than sending a train that can
photograph 70 000 uh pictures uh per
minute in order to improve safety on our
Railway why in system on these outdated
work practices if we did those things
then actually that would help to pay for
for pay Rises okay talking about new
technology that's allowed us to delve
into our Westminster accounts you've
seen it of course haven't you um I want
to show our viewers what the situation
is with yours you've not actually taken
that much money really in donations but
um there is a challenge I mean you had a
difficult transition between jobs when
you first started as an MP what do you
think the boundaries should be for MPS
and second jobs yeah look I I think that
it's important that just by the way I
thought the the work that Sky another's
done was was very good and it's um it's
important that you have transparency
it's what sets us apart from you know
other uh less Democratic societies so
that's really should end piece our
second job so but but and on second jobs
I don't have any objection
um to MPS as long as they do their main
work of being an MP having a an insight
into the outside world and I think
sometimes that work can be very helpful
one of my colleagues for example is a is
a nurse there's a doctor's I think those
things can be very helpful and sometimes
industry experience is helpful the main
thing is that they put eight million
pounds for Theresa May can she earn that
sort of money and still be a good well I
actually I think the answer is simply
yes I think she's actually one of the
most effective and everyone would say
this in Parliament one of the most
effective constituency MPS there there
is obviously in Theresa May's case she's
been prime minister there's probably
probably quite a hot ticket in terms of
making speeches which is where she makes
that money the only other thing I should
point out actually
um uh just so it's clear for people
what the sky and horses reviews done is
rolled up both uh outside earnings but
also just donations often to their local
party often to be used for campaigns in
the constituencies so um yes this is an
MPS I don't think in particular in my
case this is not me actually earning any
of that money at all yeah we do make
that clear as well we don't know whether
donations necessarily are going to and
we don't know whether you give them to
charity or not and we've made that clear
as part of the sure we're out of time
but will you be watch will you be
reading I I fear with pressure of work
it won't be my first priority but I but
it's it's great that that you guys are I
mean we can we can we can get this all
from you
look I I follow the long-standing uh
convention that cabinet ministers just
don't get into commenting on the royal
family thank goodness
we can leave it to them and to the to
the media but uh you know obviously
there's a lot going on there and I I
think that uh it's not helped one bit by
cabinet ministers commenting on it okay
um happy new year thanks for coming in
so much appreciated as always thank you